are we ready with the it's ready to make
a start
ian
yeah okay good evening everybody and
welcome to tonight's budget executive
meeting and
item one is attendances i have received
apologies from um councillor wright
councillor whittem maybe running late
but may not make this meeting
item two is declarations of interest and
they're in declarations of interest that
anybody needs to make
no
item three is the executive's revenue
budget proposal so 2223 and mtfs 23 24
24 25 councillor ops please
thank you very much and it gives me
great pleasure to
recommend uh the council budget for 2223
to executive for recommendation to the
council obviously we will be saving a
lot of what we have to say for the
council meeting but at this point in
time i'm asking that the rec the
executive recommend
that the uh a recommendation is set out
in the papers a to
p
we all know a to um u
in addition to further uh
recommendations from v to double b so
there's a number of recommendations in
there so i am hoping that you've all
read the papers which i know you will
have done one thing to say though there
has been a late amendment um to do with
the um
with the um
council tax calculation so it's not
significant but annex j has been amended
a paper went round all councillors this
afternoon we're talking pounds and pence
as opposed to anything major but we have
to get that right as part of the budget
proposals happy to take any questions at
this stage if not look forward to the
main debate thanks councillor ross any
questions or comments from members of
the executive
questions or comments more widely
a castler acton
on now you're um
yeah just just briefly um i i do welcome
the executive response to the
scrutiny budget report and welcome the
commitment to
work with screwed scrutiny throughout
the coming year i think it is important
that
you know that the scrutiny is able to
monitor some of the issues that are
raised within the budget so i'm really
pleased with the response that i think
and yeah thank you thanks cancer acting
counselor evidence
really just like to echo uh
counteracting we welcome er old scrutiny
and i think he does a good job there so
thank you thank you for your support on
the budget
any other questions or comments
counselor mrs backburn
thank you leader could um
um counselor ross or yourself just
clarify something on them page
64
4.3.1
uh it mentions children's services
0.5 million to reflect the increase in
complexity of cases and then it says a
reduction of the same amount since the
draft budget
so
is does that mean that um that there
hasn't been um any change
so my understanding of that and
councillor heinz may wish to take that
away and clarify for you um but my
understanding of that is that we had
estimated in the draft budget that there
would be some complex
cases requiring more
costly placements and through careful
management of
placements and case loads etc that the
need for that has been diminished
councillor heinz is agreeing with me but
we will double check that for you and
come back to you yeah
could i just ask as well and there's
still um monies left in the budget um
with regard to the ofsted
recommendations
will will that be clawed back or that
money still be ring fenced and used for
you know for the for the ongoing work
do you want to comment counsellor yes
sorry
yes and that will still be used for the
ongoing work yeah
and
thirdly
page 99 the income and savings proposals
um will
any sort of change in in sort of the
staffing or the
um
you know the makeup of the
department will that be discussed at
scrutiny
and that would be a matter for scrutiny
i think to pick up if they want to and
but just to sort of explain
where those savings have been identified
they actually do relate to
the fact that the
um
the numbers of children coming into um
into the service the looks after um
children numbers
have now stabilized and have actually uh
come down and as a result of that and
the complexity um is
is not at the level it was so
in some of the staffing there isn't a
requirement for the same levels now that
is in terms of posts
not
in terms of
um of people and so that's where those
staffing kind of um
figures have come from
okay but with what we are actually
investing in um
sorry and just to explain we are
actually investing in further posts but
those specific posts
in that specific area um are potentially
now not required and that's why that's
gone in there
any other questions or comments
okay the plethora of recommendations
that council ross
moved earlier have um have been moved
can they be approved please
thank you and then moving on to
the next item item for is the capital
strategy asset investment strategy
capital program on prudential and local
indicators 2022 2025 council ross please
thank you there are there are fewer
recommendations to go through here so
the exact we're asking the executive to
approve the capital program as detailed
in appendix 2 of the report
um schemes to be undertaken from the
block budget allocations reported in
paragraph 21 and detailed in appendix 4
and then we're asking the executive to
recommend the council approve the
capital strategy included in appendix
one the overall capital project as a
program
additional prudential borrowing of 50.52
million as detailed in paragraph 12 the
prudential and local indicators is set
out in appendix 3 of the report the
asset investment strategy included in
appendix 5 we're also asking the council
the executive to recommend to a council
to approve the flexible use of capital
receipts up to 0.27 million to support
the cost of the modernization team in
developing the council's finance and
change programme and the flexible use of
capital receipts strategy as detailed in
paragraph 16 of the report
thanks cancel the ross questions or
comments from members of the executive
questions or comments more widely
counselor evans
thank you thank you chair um
in section two the asset investment
strategy really just want it noted um
the conservative group increasingly
concerned at the level of risk that
we're undertaking on that and
that's it i think that the the profiling
of risk we have quite a few doubts about
and we're taking
riskier and investment so i think that
needs some careful attention just want
that noting really that
i don't we've gone from totally
supporting it to move into a bit of a
dubious situation at this point thank
you
thanks councillor evans any other
questions or comments
no okay recommendations are as set out
in the report can they be agreed
please hi
thank you item five treasury management
strategy
2223-24-25 councillor ross please
thank you this is a recommendation made
from the accounts and audit committee
for us to
note thanks cancer ross any questions or
comments from members of the exact
questions or comments more widely
recommendations uh to note as per the
report can that be agreed please
thank you item six is the strategic land
review program
2223 part one um in the absence of
councillor right i will move this report
there are a series of recommendations
set out on pages one
and two
of the report are there any questions or
comments from members of the executive
questions or comments more widely
no recommendations as per the report can
they be agreed please
thank you
item 7 is fees charges and allowances
2022-23
councillor ross please
thank you the fees and charges are set
out in the report and i'm asking the
executive recommend the council the fees
and charges for 2223 related to the
registration of birth deaths and
marriages and allotments also shown for
23 24 and set out in the booklet
available on the council's website
the approval is delegated jointly to
each corporate director and the director
of financial assistance to amend the
fees and charges which are within their
respective delegated powers during the
next budget year in the event of any
change in the rate of v80 as appropriate
and that the approve will be delegated
to each corporate director and the
director of financial and finance and
systems to amend charges during changes
during the 22-23 which are within their
respective delegated powers where the
economics of the chain charge levels
have changed eg
costs have risen unexpectedly or for
commercial reasons
thank you councillor ross any questions
or comments from members of the
executive questions or comments more
widely
no okay recommendations as per the
report can they be agreed please
thank you item eight is the executive's
response to the scrutiny committee's
recommendations to the budget proposals
for
2022-23 councillor ross please thank you
further to the report being provided to
us at the previous executive meeting in
january the executive has now responded
and i'm looking for this to be approved
thank you councillor ross questions or
comments members of the executive
questions or comments more widely
no okay
can that be noted in recommendations
agreed please
thank you item nine is urgent business
of which there is none item 10 is the
exclusion resolution which as you know i
always like to read out
that which reads that the public be
excluded from this meeting during
consideration of the remaining items on
the agenda because of the likelihood of
disclosure of exempt information which
falls within one or more descriptive
category or categories of the local
government